foreign
hey what's going on everybody it's ETA
Prime back here again today we're going
to be taking a look at and testing out
the Intel Arc a770 Phantom gaming 16
gigabyte overclocked version from ASRock
if you're familiar with the Intel Arc
series of gpus you know that Intel has
really been working on driver updates to
improve performance across the board
with all kinds of games and recently we
got a really nice one in August Intel is
claiming that we can see up to a 19
increase in frame rates with DirectX 11
games and from what I've tested so far
yeah I mean these driver updates have
been pumping out and a lot of them have
made a big difference in dx9 and DirectX
11 gaming at the time I'm making this
video you can pick up the ASRock Phantom
gaming a770 8 gigabyte model for around
249 and the 16 gigabyte model the one
we're going to be taking a look at in
this video is 299 so they're very
competitively priced when you compare it
to the others on the market right now
and I'm a huge fan of these Arc gpus you
know Intel does have kind of a lot to
gain here with driver updates a lot of
the other manufacturers have drivers
kind of fleshed out we'll see a little
bit of an increase here and there but
from launch when it comes to these Arc
gpus something like CS go we're seeing
around a 43 increase in performance
gains from the original driver to the
one that's out right now obviously
ASRock has slapped a pretty beefy cooler
on this a770 this is their Phantom
gaming 3x cooling system so we've got
those triple fans this also utilizes
their Ultra fit heat pipe system copper
base and high density metal welding to
improve heat dissipation I'll tell you
right now this thing running at full
boat 100 GPU load still super quiet
these fans don't have to spin up that
much to keep it nice and chilly and I've
never seen it hit thermal throttle and
when it comes to IO this Intel a77 has
three display ports these are 2.0 and
we've got one HDMI 2.1 port and of
course we do need to send a little extra
power to the a77 to get it up and
running so this is going to be handled
by two 8-pin pcie connectors they
recommend up to a 700 watt power supply
with this and that's really going to
depend on the CPU you opt to use with
your build
now when it comes to the overall
specifications of the Intel Arc a770
remember this is the ASRock Phantom
gaming 16 gigabyte overclock Edition
this is pcie 4.0 we get 16 gigabytes of
G ddr6 running at a 256 bus remember
they also offer an 8 gigabyte model
which will come in a bit cheaper
base core clock here is 2200 megahertz
with a boost clock up to 2400 megahertz
it's got 512 Intel xmx engines 512
tensor cores 32 RT cores and it's rated
at a 225 watt TDP in its stock
configuration so as for testing this
card out we do need to slam it inside of
a PC and I'm going to go a bit Overkill
with the CPU option here just so we
don't have any kind of CPU bottleneck I
want to see what this a770 can really do
so I'm going to be putting this inside
of my main rig I've got an I9 13900k
that's being cooled by 380 millimeter
liquimax 3. we've got 32 gigabytes of
ddr5 running at 6000 megahertz two
terabyte nvme SSD and an 850 watt power
supply and this is all inside of an
antec case and as for the operating
system we've got Windows 11 Pro fully
updated installed ready to go I just
went with the vertical GPU Mount that's
what I was using originally so I just
slapped this a770 in here and I think it
actually really goes together quite well
okay so here we are been up and running
for a little while now everything's
working really well as you can see we've
got that 13 900k definitely overkill for
the a770 but we're not going to be
working with any kind of CPU bottleneck
here and of course the arc a770 the 16
gigabyte version with The Arc drivers we
do get the art control panel and I'm on
the latest beta right now from here
we've got a lot that we can work with we
can set up custom profiles for each game
we've got our performance section and
there's actually a really nice little
overlay that you can uh put on screen at
any time
gives us all the information we need to
know about the GPU itself but we've also
got some Performance Tuning right here
so we've got a GPU boost and you know
from the control panel we can go up 100
megahertz we can set the voltage offset
and we can also up the power limit so
usually I set around 240. we've also got
a temperature limit that we can adjust
here and fan control but with this giant
cooler on the a770 from ASRock it's not
going to hit thermal throttle I could
turn these fans way down and still be
totally fine with it so I don't even
need to mess with these so obviously
we're going to be testing out a bunch of
games here and with these tests I wanted
to go to 1440p and see if we could do it
with no resolution scale via XE SS or
FSR or anything like that but the first
thing I wanted to take a look at were
some benchmarks that I ran on this
and the first one we have here is 3dmark
night raid coming in with the 76
586 and I am seeing a bit of a jump on
the GPU When comparing older drivers on
this a770 but the next one here is fire
strike with a 29 761 and finally we've
got time spy with a 14 326.
so compared to the last time I ran these
which I'll admit was actually on the 8
gigabyte model of the a770 I'm seeing
around a four percent increase in
benchmarks and it's really not that much
I could probably run the same benchmarks
on each system a few times and beat each
other out by that much so really where
the performance is going to be had with
these newer Arc updates is real world
gaming and the first one we have here is
Street Fighter 6 we're at 4K very high
personally I like running my fighting
games at 60 FPS but if you wanted to do
120 on the a770 you could do it at 1440p
and when it comes to other fighting
games we've got more than enough GPU
power here for 1440p and even 4K
depending on your settings and even
older fighting games like Street Fighter
5 are going to perform absolutely
amazing on the arc a770. is
next up we've got CS go at 1440p very
high and uh this is where Intel really
stresses that these driver updates help
with performance and it definitely shows
here before this new update with cs go
at 1440p very high I was getting an
average of around 260 FPS on basically
the same setup but by the end of this
run I had an average of 328 FPS which is
a really nice increase in fact it's
about a 22 percent increase in frame
rate with cs go
I also wanted to test out Horizon zero
Dawn at 1440p Ultra I got an average of
68 FPS so it's actually expecting a
little more and of course with some
resolution scaling we could definitely
get a lot more out of it at 1440p or you
know if you don't mind running at 1080
this game still looks great 1080p Ultra
next on the list we've got Spider-Man
Miles Morales 1440p very high and you're
going to see the same kind of
performance with Spider-Man remastered I
mean it's basically the same game
running in the same engine we got an
average of 84 FPS with this at 1440p
really great performance and you know
with this one we don't have any kind of
resolution scale we can access xcss
Intel scaling option but I didn't even
have to turn it on for this
foreign
game I always go back to with these Arc
updates is God of War when Arc was
initially released performance here was
not great at all but right now we're at
1440p Ultra and we're seeing kind of the
same frame rate as The Last Driver
updates I'm not very impressed with Arc
in this game here I'm not exactly sure
what it is but we got an average of 65
FPS
together
in the final game I wanted to test here
was cyberpunk 2077. we're at 1440p Ultra
with no resolution scale and I'm only
seeing around a 2 FPS increase from the
older drivers but it is playable and I
never saw a dip under 60 FPS so locking
this down at 1440p Ultra is definitely
playable on the a770 or resolution scale
is always a great way to up that frame
rate
so overall the Intel Arc a770 Phantom
gaming 16 gigabyte overclock Edition is
a great card in my opinion I do love
these art cards and with all of these
new driver updates the Intel's been
throwing at us we're seeing a nice boost
in performance across the board and I
suspect we will see a bit more down the
road when it comes down to it there's
two other major players in the GPU
market and they've got their drivers
kind of fleshed out across the board
like a mentioned Intel does have a lot
to gain from driver updates there's
still figuring everything out with these
gpus but I'm really glad to see him keep
on it and right now at the time of
making this video this is their most
powerful Intel Art Car the a770 uh we
haven't seen anything above this just
yet they do have a few lower end tiers
like the A50 and the A380 but you know
if you're looking for the maximum
performance out of Intel art then this
is definitely one for you now if you're
interested in learning a little more
about the Intel Arc a770 Phantom gaming
from ASRock I will leave some links in
the description again they offer an 8
gigabyte model which might be good for
some people especially if you want to
save a little money but we've also got
the higher end 16 gigabyte model the one
we took a look at here I'll leave links
for both in the description and if
there's anything else you want to see
tested with these Intel art cards just
let me know in the comments below but
that's going to wrap it up for this one
and like always thanks for watching